so in an effort to help you get caught
up on Superman I've decided that in
addition to running over his origin
story I would provide you with his story
arc from the new 52 that leads into
Superman truth and so the first thing I
want to do is start with the difference
between Action Comics and Superman
comics
when DC first launched the new 52 the
first six issues of Justice League
served as a linchpin of sorts in that in
those issues Batman Green Lantern the
flash Wonder Woman's cyborg and Superman
had all met for the first time with that
in mind while DC hasn't provided us with
a definitive answer to this the
relationship between Action Comics and
Superman comics seems to be that the
first six or seven issues of Action
Comics deal with Superman when he first
arrives in Metropolis and begins acting
as a superhero
the Superman's solo series on the other
hand takes place several years after
Action Comics but immediately before his
meeting with Justice League now as a two
we continue forward depicting Superman
during these two different areas of his
life around issue number 10 or so of
Action Comics DC began to skip forward
in time so that by issue number 22
Action Comics caught up with Superman
comics allowing both publications to
tell a more complete story from two
different directions and so as it stands
now these Superman series focuses solely
on Superman itself with occasional
appearances from a supporting cast the
Action Comics series focuses on Superman
but also includes larger roles from a
supporting cast having said that in
terms of stories leading into the
current events of Superman truth there
really isn't a lot going on here but if
all you're looking for is to get into
the Superman truth event the yellow
required reading here is Geoff Johns run
titled men of tomorrow centering on the
arrival of a character named Ulysses the
purpose of DC riding men of tomorrow was
to set up the events for Superman truth
and that men of tomorrow introduced
Superman super flare ability which
allowed him to disperse all of his solar
energy at once while this would leave
him in a weakened state requiring 24
hours of recuperation the events of
Superman truth pick up with the fallout
of this new ability and that Superman is
almost completely powerless he's been
rejected from the fortress of solitude
meaning he's not Kryptonian and his
identity has been publicly revealed by a
party or parties unknown
so the origin story of Superman is given
to us in Action Comics issues three five
seventeen and secret origins number one
and what we're going to find is that
this story is actually going to be
pretty short the reason why is because
in truth the origin story of Superman is
timeless and that even if they don't
know the intricacies of it most people
know the general idea that Superman was
sent from Krypton as it was destroyed
and arrived on earth to become Superman
I'm picking up with Action Comics issue
number three what we're told is that
drill rel the father of Superman had
learned that Krypton was in the process
of coming to an end
due to the core destabilizing and while
he had presented his findings to the
Hall of Science which acted as the
governing body because there had been
previous times when he declared the
Krypton was ending but nothing had
happened
he was completely ignored but
furthermore among the people of Krypton
jor-el was considered somewhat of a
quack and that his cast of declarations
of the end of the world made him seem
like somewhat of a lunatic and so
without anyone taking heed to his
warning the world of Krypton begins a
process of destruction with its people
unable to escape with the end of the
world imminent the first suggestion from
jor-el is to have his wife and kal-el
into the Phantom Zone an
interdimensional prison outside a space
and time as a way to escape Krypton's
destruction now one thing that DC passes
over that I think is worth mentioning is
that in previous continuities jor-el had
actually discovered the Phantom Zone and
use it as a way to imprison villains
from Krypton while in the Phantom Zone
individuals into her ghostly form in the
sense that they can neither interact
with the outside universe or themselves
instead they're sort of frozen in time
outside of all realities for the rest of
eternity nonetheless as is explained to
us in the Phantom Zone
jor-el could use a time to attempt to
engineer their escape and find new home
for themselves however as they prepare
to enter General Zod along with others
who had previously been imprisoned
attempt to exit the Phantom Zone and
attack jor-el jumping in an attacking
Zod Krypto the dog is actually pulled
into the Phantom Zone and the access
gate is shattered meaning no one can
enter or leave from that location and
turning their attention to a prototype
rocket designed as a blueprint for
saving the people of Krypton jor-el
states that it was only designed to
house animals and that neither himself
nor his wife can actually enter it and
so because the red Sun of Krypton
suppresses the powers of Kryptonians
jor-el places kal-el inside the
so instructs the brainiac AI to locate a
planet with a Yellow Sun and a low
gravity which would allow Superman to
access his abilities and fly and so with
the ship taking off kal-el and his wife
lura LaVon stay behind as the planet
comes to an end and from here we
transition to earth where we meet
Jonathan and Martha Kent while stranded
in the winter due to a flat tire we also
learned that Martha and Jonathan had
previously tried having a baby but had
been unable to conceive however in the
midst of their discussion the craft
containing Superman actually Sears
through the atmosphere and lands next to
them investigating the site Martha and
Jonathan find kal-el but after realizing
the Superman's arrival would inevitably
alert the military
Jonathan alongside Martha and Superman
immediately leave now picking up with
Secret Origins number 1 we learned that
following his adoption by the Kent's the
Superman's abilities manifested at a
very young age well as heat vision had
caused a good amount of damage to the
property around him the Kent's also
realized at the time would come when he
needed to know about his heritage while
I haven't been able to find this
particular moment outside of its being
mentioned in secret origins the Kent's
provide Superman with a blanket he was
wrapped in after being sent from Krypton
which he then turns around and fashions
into a cape what we also learned is that
as a child
Superman was taught to understand that
his strength was something to be used as
a force for good and never to be used in
anger and so when a group of kids pick a
fight Superman never actually engages
them and instead is saved by Martha who
runs the children off with a broom now
in Action Comics issue number 17 DC
establishes that prior to Superman
moving to Metropolis to operate as a
hero both Martha and Jonathan were
involved in a car wreck with a drunk
driver while Martha was immediately
killed in the collision
Jonathan survived but sustained mortal
wounds that would actually go on to kill
him now I'd like you to pay special
attention to what happens next with his
last wish being to die at home Superman
takes Jonathan Kent back to the farm in
Smallville where he says that while
Superman has vast powers he can't be
everywhere at once to save everyone now
again this is particularly important
here because this will actually serve as
Superman's motivation for becoming a
superhero but following the death of
Jonathan Kent we transition back to
secret origins number 1 where we learn
that with Martha and Jonathan having
I'd the Superman feels an almost
complete lack of connection with the
world around him and where he initially
finds himself in a dark place both
emotionally and mentally his experiences
being raised by Martha and Jonathan
alongside words passed on to him through
a message by his mother regarding what
it means to love enable him to step into
the role of becoming Superman with that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it and I will catch you guys later peace